[Musique]
le roi arthur à la recherche de sa chair
emeline compter au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
après anna dj de endel jérôme correas et
les paladins s'attaque à l'oeuvre de
henry purcell une création commandée par
le théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
à laquelle s'est associé le chorégraphe
louis barrault c'est un opéra donc ça
veut dire qu'il ya un livre est donc une
histoire
or moi j'ai beaucoup l'habitude notant
que chorégraphe de plutôt mettre en
place des formes on va dire abstraite
c'est à dire que j'aime bien ne pas
chercher à raconter une histoire mais
plutôt à organiser dans l'espace des
formes des balades et des mouvements des
relations une création débuté il ya
plusieurs mois sur scène quatre solistes
professionnels et 300 amateurs des
adultes et des élèves des écoles du
territoire
ces quatre écoles qui sont très
différentes ça c'est aussi intéressant
puisque c'est d'aider des mondes qui
n'ont rien à voir
voilà il ya des enfants il ya des
enfants qui viennent de milieux très
aisé d'autres au contraire beaucoup
moins et c'est des gens qui se
rencontrent sur scène et qui d'un seul
coup sûr le plateau se retrouve un état
un état d'égalité totale presque je me
suis adapté en proposant des choses
simples et en même temps c'est parfois
les choses les plus simples qui demande
le plus de concentration et d'attention
vis-à-vis du groupe en fait pendant plus
d'une heure les artistes vous emmèneront
au coeur de l'angleterre
tout en se questionnant sur les idéaux
de la chevalerie la solidarité et la
justice